[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
Ausgabe von Homeshopping mit mir Gernot
Paradeiser und meinem wunderbaren
Kollegen mein Name ist Graz
heute haben wir ein ganz ganz tolles
Produkt für Sie wirklich diesen
wunderbaren banana Slicer das ist ein
was ein banana Slicer und was macht man
mit einem Bananen
genau Bananas leisten es ist wunderbar
wenn Sie zum Beispiel in der Früh eine
Müsli machen oder eine schöne Bowl dann
nehmen Sie sich einfach eine Banane
stellen diese Banane ab ne das will man
halt so macht der Kollege Kreuz
ist schon daneben gegangen
oder bitte und man legt diese wunderbare
Banane hin platziert den Slicer auf der
Banane und wie funktioniert das genau
und jetzt gibst du mir deine Fingerchen
und drückst langsam oft ins leise von
oben drauf und dann wirst du sehen dass
du wunderschön wunderbare Scheibchen
erzeugt ich kann es nicht glauben
ja sie sehen schon meine Damen und
Herren wir haben hier
wunderbares leises erzeugt hier in den
schönen gitterkammern und die nimmt man
jetzt behutsam heraus ganz elegantes
lesses sind das und du sie überall das
ist so tolle Scheiben geworden sind
genau kann es nicht glauben und es tut
mir jetzt über die Bowl ja weißt doch so
drauf drückst wie nachher so und sie
sehen selber das ist das perfekte Doping
für eine Bowl oder ein schönes Müsli
dass sie in der Früh genießen möchten
meine Damen und Herren man muss sich
derzeit ein bisschen in der Deko
vorstellen wie das dann eines leise ist
einfach eine groß ist toll dass man
Bananen so Fleisch essen kann aber man
kann es auch anders machen
dieses Produkt jetzt bei uns erhältlich
zum Vorzugspreis von nur 39,99
bestellen Sie jetzt ich glaube wir haben
noch einige auf Lager
oder so
[Applaus]
oben drauf wie sah Elefant also wirklich
seinen die Leute denken da das ist eines
der halt dann einfach vor
kein Bock mehr
[Applaus]